hey guys welcome to our launch day
livestream for Call of Duty World War
two this is all brought to you by
Activision my name is chasity we have
some very special guests here today we
have two teams they'll be going against
each other we have team screwattack
versus team warp zone so let's check out
our guests first team ScrewAttack is
here we've got Chad and Sam hey guys hey
how's it going how's it going oh we're
just ready to destroy some people so
you've played a lot of cod yeah yeah so
you're ready for this is your first time
playing cod World War 2 yeah I've been
related to check it out and well I mean
we we practiced a little bit ahead of
time and I'm really digging it so yeah
I've been I've been stoked for this one
for a while because I've always said
world of war even though everyone hated
that was my favorite Call of Duty right
before so I'm really happy to get back
there you know world war ii and all that
good stuff good okay let's check in with
your other team the vs. team is right
here zone 2 Michael's are back hey guys
how's it going
good morning or afternoon anyone where
you are you excited yeah I feel about
you right how you feeling about called
World War 2 oh great good played a total
of two matches and I'm excited feels
good feels feels like Call of Duty it's
like riding riding a bike it is a little
bit like riding but you took the cold
matches to get used to it excited very
excited awesome and we're also streaming
on your YouTube channel yes hello yes
cactus if you're ever in chat we're
gonna check out their checkbook we're
also on GameSpot's youtube and
GameSpot's switch and gamespot.com
so wherever you want to join the chat I
will be fielding questions during the
matches so we're gonna be doing team
deathmatch
and war mode today so we're gonna start
with team deathmatch so we're gonna jump
into a game very soon you guys ready oh
yeah all right so we're gonna wait for
this match to start oh you have access
in LA so who's accident and who's atlas
so we're axis today we're all allies in
real life so yeah look at that see and I
was just about to tell them that
whenever you guys are on camera feel
free to chrome out the background and
put you guys in compromise
all right here we go team deathmatch so
you'll see on the screen which team
you're spectating so sometimes we'll be
watching team score attack sometimes
you'll be watching team warp zone it'll
say when it's on yeah no I can't screw
up everyone that robot from Futurama
yeah yeah there are five divisions to
choose from lit so this one has Sam look
at maggots look at me oh my god
discovered color people can see the only
thing we can do after discovering color
is murder other people it wasn't World
War two in black and white I don't know
if you know that like the losing team
has to live in black and white for the
rest of their life that's the tragic
side they turn it oh we're right next to
each other - oh you're bad I get to
watch you both die together hold hands
okay yeah that's fun I'm glad there's no
team attacking this because boy am i
good to go oh sorry
yeah you know who else did so you want
to be false here oh this is triple
are you guys having fun World War two
names over there oh yeah baby secrete
every time we do a sketch with a war
femur Oh guns we need to have a quality
it's such a cool like wartime name
you have to yell I also like Jonesy
that's a good one too oh this loadout
has the killstreak so that's good that
is good so yeah turning the corner and
they were do you there right now we're
looking at team warp zone no pressure
okay
yes you can watch the guys Joakim online
killcam yeah I mean okay at least you
still see an action I guess let's see
yeah this room you want yeah you do see
someone to get shot all right
oh no we got radar ah Tony Tony from
Ghana benjin you meters up yeah and I'm
back now I'll use that that's a win-win
trying to get these bayonet charges in
sometimes guns just you know bullets are
faster stuff I mean usually yes bullets
are faster than a bayonet Sam yeah but
it doesn't have the satisfaction than
bayonet duster oh did I get it okay
where more of them died in that
encounter oh good shot alright radars up
Davis okay they've got radar that's all
we got it's artillery to you yep
they relying the hey when they
definitely had more than radar that's a
double kill
how are you
what is that big blue circle yeah uh
it's a it's a friend zone where
everybody gets free ice cream with Froyo
your choice but you can never go beyond
that friend zone yeah
everyone goes out for ice cream yeah
there we are
after this no matter who wins we all go
up from it's creepy up and that's how
World War two could have been settled
wasn't there like a time though where
they did stop and like celebrate
Christmas or something that was three oh
damn all right Oh Davis I'm sorry yeah
we're or Jim do that
down by seven no it's not I saw that you
can come on bean house I guess oh no you
don't I think they were saying bagging
this and this I'm 40 here whatever smg's
run-and-gun yeah that's some about to
switch to so we're watching TV 44 that's
a score sterno they've got the game spot
ringer on their team Oh Oh tea mission
begins hey okay hey you shot me too
boom oh good
melee I forgot how satisfying you are no
nothing that English a little punch in
the face oh okay
one sake not easy Dan gotta watch out
this isn't destiny let me do you know
what this that that gun wasn't really
working for me I'm gonna try something
else
go away we are blaming it on the gun
that's a good idea I'm gonna do that
next
oh yeah what's happening I'm I'm aiming
at them ooh
oh it's a little scary from where I'm
set up there we go oh there's two all
right let's see what a mortar strike
does you're not even given does that
kill people I didn't how do you got
anybody man which is fine for me let's
go I even know a mortar strike works I
was just like Oh points on the map let's
see what happens boom two more not even
positive alright what happened there
guys well they philanthropy from games
[Laughter]
[Music]
we have one match team warp zone good
job guys so we're gonna do another team
deathmatch very soon how'd that feel
team warp zone it's got the team warp
zone what yeah I play a lot of call duty
and my really go to his running gun so
finding the world war two equivalent of
running gun was really important then I
think it's working out so nice I'm happy
how's it feeling for you Davis because
I'm just trying to figure out what gun
is really mean yeah you know you know
the first one I'd match yet
it has like it has like a lime green
coloring on it - I think that's
the way that my position in this yeah I
don't know I'll figure it out
[Laughter]
so we're gonna wait for this next match
um let's see if we have any questions
we're on the chat rooms over on YouTube
and twitch and also the warp zones yeah
YouTube so let's see if we have any
questions right now
chad is talking about ice cream ice
cream so much everyone wants ice cream
here's a snow level jumping back to Team
Deathmatch favorite flavor ice cream
guys with something else in it as always
see that's what I was really gonna do so
place comes hard
whatever Ben & Jerry's has cramped the
most stuff in like the cookie dough and
the nuts in the show we use you get a
cold stone you get poor cheesecake on
one side you get this is gonna think I
should pick two different now we're
playing team deathmatch again we've got
team warp zone versus team spirit
lagging in replace all Duty World War
two
brought to you by Activision its launch
day and they're getting some support
from some game starters in our GameSpot
office each other oh goodness that was
not a great start for me do we have
you don't have the rear cuz I'm so long
the Allies team targets over on Twitch
for epic says can you tell chance to do
boomstick voice what are you talking
about
there you go nice let's see don't think
we totally love World War one and that
sounds awful
but you like the guns so what I was
getting it's hard to speak well okay got
a head shot that's kind of fun make you
feel good from behind and then behind I
got freaked out there alright where are
we here oh no your name and war is
really unfair struggle words like yes so
much dying people don't respond so much
in World War two we keep flipping the
spawns okay oh yeah that's fun watching
team warp zone right now
Oh watch your positions goes in what
sense in that they have their radar boat
and that would have managed to be a snow
fun Oh just poop that's what they said
back then oh gee willikers golly gee
well isn't that just swell yep
good one oh darn it I think I just saw
you die this gun is the bee's knees
plant repeat is a bully well he is
controlling the match so sorry well for
him all right all right all right all
right all right breathe I can't tell you
because I'm using
inside-joke so that I know where you are
but nobody else can guess it okay oh
nice Oh surprise people
oh yeah oh okay I'm a good time we
didn't square I yeah so at least you
guys chill for a second just trying to
go soon
oh no they're coming oh yeah that is the
most satisfying thing right now is that
I see the circle business Matthew and
that is so satisfying now here we go
let's say Louis does
nobody with the artillery really blows
no one kid but I got it I'm doing real
good right now
there's some more counter you know you
just have to select it
mr. perfect okay we're just a little
behind but everyone knows we're a second
half team
wait Dave ah what oh look I see the
problem
Dave's your axis right now oh wait why
am I the sole warp some guy on oh you
can switch who was on whose team just
[Laughter]
knows my the goal and I feel like a Oh a
three in that one I feel pretty good not
even score
I'm good series numbers all right let's
go switch back I have to switch back to
evil eye is weird I told him to send me
axis but it's effective all right let's
say you have the thing where you don't
it feels really really solid personally
like I'm glad that it's going back to
the roots of like you focus on your gun
your map awareness who where you need to
get who you need to kill right a lot
less of the frantic insanity of boosting
your rocket packs and running on walls
and some people really like that but for
me Cod was about that just like you have
your gun you find the people and you
have a you have a gun fight you know and
I really love that it's finally coming
back to that a lot more its same reasons
like I hated when it got too fast in we
had jetpacks like playing this dough is
just back to the good old days I'm good
very nice it's awesome what are you guys
thinking how's this Cod feeling the
opposite opinion but I love jetpacks is
so much fun
yes I just want him into this video game
the real-life video they could add
jetpacks later and it was like some
rocketeers to the match make sure that
you're on the right teams yes I think I
think that I'm on the right team now so
technically does it who does that win
count four counts for the viewers I'm
gonna pull you I don't know this map so
no no follow the bots no give me some of
these maps I have no idea what this map
is so we're on a boat oh there's some
bad people there's lots of windows to
shoot heads that there's a lot there
only schools around me okay well because
we're the axis chat kind of a bad guy
staple right no I mean like our team guy
yeah oh there's a lot of them there you
go I'm sending people to join
Oh somebody came up behind me oh sorry
he's thinking running gun watched always
watch your back oh good go at your back
I like what you guys are doing don't you
leave your backs and sighs expose thank
you oh yeah how did that not kill you
Randolph Davis oh boy stood by another
person was another guy oh great ringers
on the opposite team all right it's fine
we're J don't ya come on this I've got a
bazooka so I'm feeling better about it
got an assist okay okay yeah that's good
I got an assist I feel good about it
assists are good
Sammy trying to sneak up on my boys yes
I was and I had my bazooka I was trying
to bazooka them in the back oh we're at
your position cuz you're right behind me
this is watcher oh okay oh god camping
in the corner don't worry kid
smack him that's gone through because
they just get shot whatever sprint along
dude yeah he's gotta get to a spot and
then there we go
keep firing
yeah yeah watch your back radars up
their arse arse so if you guys are just
tuning in we're playing Call of Duty
World War two oh come on Activision
you're watching team warp zone right now
and they are facing off with team
screwattack and they're here playing
team deathmatch you can't tell by our
faces and the silence it's getting oh
that was an explosion okay I'm gonna run
away from that yes I'm happy for you
contribute in a way has some yeah it was
screwed there but I got a head shot that
felt good yeah all right a lot of people
I see a lot of red over there so well
yes there's nothing spawn yeah that
would track oh come on make sense so
close to the double kill boom
oh those are some grenades there were
two in there they get a grenade cute
yeah got a ball all right how does this
work
I miss that was bad it's really creepy
with all the explosions and smoke going
around there's that like you know cool
walkthrough on how to do it I just I
thought yeah save we had a vote on the
Mike looks okay we're good we're good
we're good
oh there's two you everything's free me
how do I not mess this one up
don't know I haven't used it okay go get
in time yeah I mean he doesn't have one
guys you should come outside it's a
really nice day no no I think you yeah
you got me with the barrage all right
watch your back
oh no I'm on to your tricks where is it
the radar they go to the I love my
matter-of-factly the Raiders up go to
the thing there we go that was really
shitty now like you can the answers
right there oh yes yes this is my time
see yeah you got it
well there's some more counter UAV
beautiful yeah enjoy being blind how do
you get more mo you're running out of
ammo killstreak right now I guess let
this pick up somebody up that's not a
gun in ways alright let's explore
something coming for my kill three
people killed was that's done six healed
and that was the ring or two I couldn't
get inside from where I was sorry nah
yeah everybody it's got a little bit
away from us this time the winds yeah no
we do good to light machine guns take
about you like turn it around lik game
there turned it around good map that's a
good yeah we're talking my high confirm
my gun lasso I think I might have found
it which gun
yeah mp40 nice so what happened there
guys oh yeah some of us learning the
mass of us who is so excited about our
teammates that we dropped our bombs on
them that pretty close good not really
you find it on you Mike Reider mm-hmm oh
yeah since the beginning I was like mmm
p4 he's gonna be mine are you thinking
with the same division uh yeah yeah
which one did you choose airborne
because it has a silencer on there that
can be a little it's funny because
you're running like so they can see you
in your when you're moving but they
can't see when they shoot nope
let's check in with team ScrewAttack
over here oh yeah every after every get
caught on to Schroeder's tactics oh yeah
just run and go in flanking so any time
I felt that there was a moment of safety
I would turn around and watch him run
through a doorway and get shot watch
your back it was pretty much oh yeah
yeah he's gonna be every game for size
but now he's gonna switch it up because
he knows what's up Oh guns like I'm
absolutely in love with the bar yeah the
only downside is like I get a lot of
impact but not a lot of ammo so like
it'll put somebody down quick what if
you miss you then you got to reload and
it's probably gonna get killed I'm
diggin the mg 15 but it has a lot of its
got like 75 rounds oh yeah I don't
reload like ever
I usually just die before I run out of
bullets that's my reload was that the
way machine gun good you brought it
again picked up yours
and I reloaded and that's where I was
like Oh mentor process yeah and then
your secondary on that to the bazooka
mm-hmm it's not effective not the way
you think a bazooka would be in World
War 2 like it landed like next to guys
foot and he was like I'm fine don't
worry about it
I've just been covered in nice so we're
waiting for our next match to start
let's check in with a chat if you're
just tuning in we're playing Call of
Duty World War 2 you brought to you by
Activision with the warp zone and
screwattack if you've got questions for
the guys please relay them on our
YouTube page on our twitch page or we're
also streaming on the warp zones YouTube
page so I will check in on the chat and
see how you guys are doing a lot of
people cheering for you guys on the warp
zone chat I would hope so is Davis sick
I might do you have a cold I think yeah
is it the voice or do I just look
I think it was your voice and they asked
how the other guys from the work zone
are doing they're probably fine they're
probably back in LA having fun yeah
getting sandwiches from a local deli
sandwiches I love it you didn't hear you
were just like they're great you're like
they're probably mean he's not gonna lie
to ya yeah all right Gibraltar this one
looks great new map Gibraltar weird see
that's pretty nice no I visited
Gibraltar have many many years ago so I
can we get like some sort of handicap
because keep one eye closed
Gibraltar they have a lot of monkeys
yeah other than one I mean the jerk they
are to me because we were on a tour and
there was an old woman with a wig I'm
sure I should feel bad about this but it
was so funny did the monkey put it on
that would really seal it I know yeah
yeah that would be impressive but no the
monkey just ripped it off oh all right
we are playing team warp zone is showing
right now so no pressure no come on
we're in the Gibraltar maverick every
time everyone just keeps running in and
on flipping it that bot is hacking yeah
that bot those bots are BOTS keep on
dying their BOTS keep on killing that's
not weird we trained them better
this map is definitely much bigger this
is
I like it's all bright though it's a
nice contrast to the scary spooky one
from before say if you're gonna you know
fight to the death somewhere it's really
somebody a nice little vacation
destination yeah I'm just really just in
the town I got are you people oh there's
one I found out I think that you can die
fall damage so that's cool and not a
neat no sir there's actually a class
that you can select okay that prevents
that from happening what the ninja class
like who doesn't get hurt but falling
SMG people apparently okay everyone
blame the class is called smg's like
cats they always land with parachutes oh
[ __ ] she got his vote I was not
expecting that
oh it's philanthropy I'm gonna have
words with him when we leave here catch
you with the spoopy stand there's a lot
of skulls over here there's also just a
lot of there's so many places to hide
yeah hey guys where are you at so George
we're just sitting there thanks bye
he's like I'm gonna sit here and snipe
in the open yes oh my god what was that
house ever name
yeah I want to say what are your BOTS
just whatever sat there is he gonna do
he's just gonna back guys yeah what I'm
just not a morning person George might
mean Milan trading doors bravely ran
into our team across the bridge without
firing a shot with the sniper rifle yeah
he's doing great
doing the Lord's work here in case
you're wondering if all that momentum
from last game carried over it didn't
you lost momentum II like you completely
none of its there or what uh it's like a
crash and I'm trying to I'm gonna try to
sprint when you're tired it's not
working and you kind of stumble and
everyone's like just stop and you're
like no I got it
there's some me off all right here we go
Oh Domino did the same thing on the
bridge these bots in this bridge I'm
having trouble that was a bummer finding
any okay there we go
I'm I try to get my berry yeah I'm
really a bear it is it is really big I'm
just like slowly going off radar you
know what take me for that come back
here yeah but rather that running that
you were talking about it's not working
for me that's we can run right to my gun
like it's like is way too much here Oh
again I like stabbing
how are you so quiet sneaky man over
bullets that time is it you - do dashing
with your little bayonets up yeah yeah
you get a little - little jokey up there
soon everybody just be cool
stabbing people like crazy Oh No ah yes
I've been wanting this I got the
firebombing room Oh No
heads up I'll throw in because I got a
molotov over here Chet so we're just
kidding I say I'm not the best on this
map obstructed obstructed I did I get it
you died looking at a map in which
everything is interrupted hopefully it
gets oh yeah everyone that was where
they did something he had a coverage man
Oh super cuz there's fire on the ground
now welcome to hell how could you oh
gosh
yeah how's that fire looking over there
you guys warm I was in a cave at first
so am I respond like what's all this hot
stuff
I just figured you know goes roast some
s'mores and stuff alright okay I think I
did get radar off so so you're proud of
me
man I shot a bot and then a human player
killed me back I shoulda shot first
yeah I feel like the box of distractions
yeah oh come on
but what's your name like steel all
right victory - we present so how many
matches have you guys want
well technically - not counting the one
the community but that's okay all right
so we're gonna move on to another match
let's take some chat questions we're
over on YouTube which and warp zones
YouTube so let's see how you guys are
doing in the chat
how you guys feeling over there warp
zone you know good still
yeah that wasn't our map but you know
nobody you don't want em all yep
someone is asking what are you playing
lately any new games that you're playing
as of Call of Duty World War 2 brought
to you a - mm-hmm Oh
destiny shame have you been anyone
playing playing on the PC yeah it's
really five sailin yeah ps4 ps4 he's got
to be like my obi-wan like walking me
through
Oh Alice oh okay yep yeah the difference
sylia halls have been playing a lot of
destiny - yeah r1 is melee and I play I
play tactical intelligence oh oh it's my
melee so I just had this muscle memory
moment you ever like fight and then
suddenly he's right there and so just
that takes over it is panics just and
then I slowly pull out the screw made
and I'm like and then I got
I keep pressing Square and I don't think
square is anything but reload so I don't
know why it's just why are you like
picking up items reflexively reloading
in the middle of a fight which is never
saved anyone's life here at the Gustav
caiman the Gustav cannon man all right
all right Team Deathmatch Gustav cannon
can i fire it let's find out goal I
don't know but that was really exciting
this is a real thing yeah it was a trade
off cannon yeah that's cool
these are all real things we don't have
enough weaponized trades I think in real
life I don't think we have enough trains
anymore in general train like last
weekend we'll get a weapon that strains
we back we pitch it to the government
and here's how we sell it we mask it
like Thomas the Tank no one will expect
but it's like a different kind of take
50 cals
yeah as you saw a couple minutes ago
they just chose from different
multiplayer divisions - all right
haven't been familiar with five
different multiplayer divisions you've
got infantry airborne armored mountain
and expeditionary meet in the killing
fields this is a Bears a big line of
large map yes the middle is not the gun
to use for that yeah I was just about to
say this is a great sniper Matt and then
face Jesus Hannah oh I'm surprised I got
that one cuz I wasn't even looking at
first you guys and their sniper rifles
yeah pretty rough out there yeah we
might have to switch Oh
or we just get to the Train the trains
where it's happened guys oh it's okay
place
- - who everyone face up on the tree oh
no - you came around crouched like you
had that do you are all stealthy ready
to go
aye that's why I got me a couple kills -
I was like this is why you're on a five
kill streak back I love the no like ace
enchilada jump and x-ray the bottoms
they're definitely ironic because I'm
like oh x-rays oh yeah only Luke your
namesake yes are you or not alright I
don't have a sniper class set I guess I
can use it people dude there is no cover
yes no the fields of death are not the
best place I really really should be
going
buzzer your snipers over there you guys
got all these ringers well it also helps
for them because right now we have six
people and they have nine wait really
yeah okay they needed one I'm switching
it was the boss I think the bots dish
you guys yeah they did a wonderful
choice Tammy I was trying to hit you in
the face
I didn't have my stammer onset oh I can
see yeah
so it was like there's a lot of bad
people around not super thrilled about
not doing well on this one switch oh I
love this game okay I got a guy at bomb
should we gonna do it
you just aim at the red that's the red
oh you know it's right that's right
you know Oh God it was me I I see the
problem my last time cuz I didn't do
that game for the team the opposite of
the red oh that was just not worth o
demon where is
based on the game before you yeah oh I
feel like the only way to survive before
this is just to do the use corner of the
map yeah coz you have stick to cover let
him come to you my guy is getting his
cardio in for serious this the world war
ii workout it's a real killer you know I
love that it's swung the other way and
now you guys have more more bots really
yeah I don't think we want more BOTS
extra manpower but you also right there
is the mortar strike only one area no
you pick three and ring
you just hit art but you you put it in
one uh it was the only red dots on the
map so like you know whenever that
happens you just kind of estimate their
spawn why do something you same spot I
mean it's okay learn and so two steps
forward and then you're doing great I am
falling apart here yep
I'm getting caught up in the crossfire
I was roasting x-ray for being terrible
and then he just grenaded me you think
they come x-ray cause he heard Jesus I
just feel like that was that's what they
were doing
yeah he should absolutely be he's also
the sniper so I think you know which is
interesting no good one I'll tell ya I
guess through technology he does Oh ace
sniped know all these guys that was
roasting for being terrible before and
now like stepping it up yeah Emily hurt
the boxer thank you yeah you inspired
they've been watching the chat will hang
it where you always easy on you
who you die thank you Oh Oh God it was
you
it's philanthropy that's our boy Ben
mm-hmm having the gamespot office this
is very interesting double agent I like
how the like the best place this knife
is in the center I don't know if
colonies ever done that before
I'm just saying hold on nope not good
just not gonna hit you from there that's
nice for sure not to think really a
sniper before classes whoa seems even it
was like right on let's see something
more even eight to seven yeah I might
need any spots for these they play by
their own rules where are we going with
this thing plan what welcome to the
fields of death oh this is rough every
time I get like a good place I'm like
what the Train and then I get shot Oh
Ben ah yeah really glad for any plot
turning fires not on
a little bit a lot of bullets in friends
faces I mean you're going to shoot
through them cuz these dogs boys stand
in front of you yeah yeah
got two victories in a row 33 in a row
three less team members on your team if
I'm not gonna lie especially because
they were they're doing real good about
sniping oh there you go
x-ray the two V's thing is a real
giveaway
you guys appear to have a bot named
sugar 313 yeah
your worst ace four and six well he's
eight is your good luck charm yeah I
Russell you like the names weren't that
bad now though we have like zebra and
King and even they they gotta come
second okay time to figure out a second
let's talk about the divisions really
quick so what do you guys think of the
multiplayer divisions it's pretty
interesting the class so I've been so
used to well when I first get in here
was a little like okay what do I do and
then I realize okay cool like all the
types of things that I like from quality
they're still here just an interface
form in a different way and so it's very
interesting that they want to
incentivize you to use certain types of
guns with a certain type of engine but
it's pretty cool because it gives you
like it by doing that you get something
extra cool are you just changing up
between divisions are you sticking with
one I'm really liking infantry yeah but
I'm a big assault rifle person no I'm
usually assault rifles or SMG they feel
good like it gives you enough of a
difference between each division that
makes you like one yeah
and you really alright so we are going
into London Docks it's actually just in
London so oh cool alright I'm gonna try
running you want to learn a little bit
more about the divisions we have a video
about all the multi player division so
you can check out on gamespot or I can
tell you a little bit about them right
now infantry is the most versatile
division in the game equipped for mid to
long range combat airborne makes players
move fast while remaining quiet zombies
right now it's definitely so snipers
fire armored that division has the
heaviest firepower and matthan has this
long-range comms focus on long-range a
positive making snipers more precise
work they've got me busy so that look at
this
an expeditionary has shotguns and
incendiary rounds I can burn em knees to
death
yep we hunt yep but there's but there's
two red dots around the statue
oh they did the same thing I did already
got seven kills up let's go on I'm good
oh it's killed security
yeah but Abel doesn't have the cool
sorry Johnny what the heck was that
that was in him okay that was like a
model Berg kuretake throat oh my god
get him got to tutor I just spawned I'll
just oh that's my own teammate
something's up how's this bunch of
whiskey barrels you'll forget this guy
I've got a whole bunch of whiskey just
chilling in here think that sounds like
a pretty good idea yeah I'm down
why can't we all just get along get
hammered together and like maybe set up
some targets reaching some target
practice that yeah all right all right
let's turn this around
oh yeah you want to go oh damn it was it
good oh yeah we're just here snow free
it's party scream there
well what about serves that in the game
who knows who's screaming that's war for
you Oh
call videos like I stopped breathing for
a moment things so I could have screamed
who knows it was kind of so good okay
yeah yeah I like this Matt better get
back on the airport train yep oh all
right
stuffs up sneaky time keep trying to
stab people mixed effects it's worked
out notable times I'm gonna bust out the
shovel here soon or Samuel shovel yeah
this is shovel yeah and you just shovel
people that's fun
holy mackerel oh oh you're right there I
was not ready for that I need to get
some worthless effing folio
how rude watch this did you call me so
happy
no no I was following someone and I
walked up tonight and it did not kill
them
yeah the Bailey's aren't like guaranteed
when he kills indoors unless you have
the bayonet I got a scary moment where
they were both looking at me but I
managed to get a double kill anyway
having played games recently that does
not have like in it bullet penetration I
can tell you in wonderful oh yeah
I killed a guy nature in front of the
baby that Kim I was trying and then you
had someone behind you that shot me down
I would have gotten you oh okay I have
radar oh use it right not coming in Oh
from behind no honor in that
this guy just running around with a
Molotov it looks terrifying that was me
just chasing fairness there was a group
there and just know your guys got killed
so yeah take what I can get No
where's all the bad people
that's the Bob's again oh I see you owe
me do Dan
is there a way to make the bombs go
faster down no I tried
oh this is all artillery yeah every time
your way streets back be over that was
close watch the side what it's a good
cause definitely yeah the most
impressive in the match all right nice
job weights now the most the most
interesting kill interesting kiss are
not like a gold star it's probably more
historically accurate like the gold star
is probably something bigger than a
three kill streak mm-hmm that's fair
are you guys looking forward to playing
zombies in this well their black ops
where you get to play as the presidents
do David Tennant's yes nazi zombies
elektra from correct
pretty exciting you guys play zombies oh
are you guys gonna play zombies when you
play more this lovably sounds like fun
alright we're waiting for our next match
we're gonna do another team deathmatch
we're playing for another hour so if you
have any questions for the guys go ahead
and drop those over on our twitch our
YouTube or warp zones
YouTube because I'm monitoring all three
right now and hanging out chestnut and
we are gonna jump into another match
very soon but if you're just tuning in
we're playing Call of Duty World War two
brought to you by Activision its launch
day we're playing on the PlayStation 4
is a play on Xbox one so play wherever
you like and we're gonna try wars the
war mode in a few minutes we're playing
for one more hour so we'll probably do
an hour of war mode okay alright now
that's from like the older sense my
reason was grace Mari Dumont is the next
map that we are going to let's check out
this next
team deathmatch over in this next map so
many giant guns around I really want to
use them this looks like it's close
crazy we'll see that's a good luck
record let's me I got sappy we're gonna
do this do this
I didn't yeah change teams really just
come out of banner yeah and you can
charge there you're uneasy faster
consummate kill well that was a lot of
read names killing blue names I don't
like that yeah I'm gonna take it back
turn surprise oh no no no you you
monster did he kamikaze one person
that's an access well then I get killed
but then the grenade was right there and
I'm bad hmm destroyed there oh that's
good there is oh man I'm not near any
grenades Aboriginals a bummer no you're
not dead what come back
I need to move there around that corner
I know that wasn't good what yeah what
corner is it bot me me the first bearson
but it's just a corpse breathing its
last breath
yep utility intensity his rhythm yeah no
that was reloading Oh what was that they
just keep flying across my screen
there's a lot of bullets oh you know
what have a grenade oh well who is that
on top of the sandbags it's ridiculous
like a spider monkey fight over here I
thought that was in Gibraltar he has the
higher ground this maps interesting
because you have these moments for like
all right everything seems calm and then
you turn a corner and it's just chaos I
got it I gotta try new weapon it's not
working for me right now got a question
on twitch from 2h2 HP before I open my
seal copy I get motion sick easy what
you guys say that this game is better or
worse than other FPS with regards to
those issues the last one was you not
moving as fast and that's crazy that's
what I would say turn your sensitivity
down I get motion sick pretty easily but
not not in these games so I don't know
if it's previous ones up top I just want
to top and boom good is using that
machine pistol doesn't work
got to bayonet stab somebody I really
want to do that
where who wants a bayonet gonna get this
Bayonetta my favorite thing and just
bein out of the guy right in the heart
it was worth every second of that death
of mine
no don't like it you know I'm having
some good luck with I switched guns to
something little bit for the range mmm
God thinking of switching guns oh oh
this little I didn't put the machine
pistol and so I was like oh man in the
war that would be crazy if they like
gave them like fear and a bunch of other
things it kind of looked like it yeah
you like talk to them with your headset
yeah I for one am on board with giving
the robots beer after that after that
you do a lot of really smart decisions
on all people's parts as walk the corner
in today see the beignet works great
when it's one person but when it's two
people yes
you guys know a little bit of a radar
radar it's great you swap a pistol out
for another someone else's gun yeah I
mean no no
what okay
Oh point-blank Chuck and shot is not a
guaranteed kill just good to know at
least not that well I will say from the
little bit I use the shotguns not a big
fan
all right we're dropping the ball here
Sam we got the cream back oh I'm so I
got to torch me right after a bayonet at
that guy no it was cool it looked cool
from my perspective there only one
behind now we got to fix that well I
just let it do not matter which side oh
interesting job and the rest will see
his corpse and they'll know strike fear
in it nope oh there's a lot of you guys
I feel bad for whoever I think it was
one here hey just you know you're bought
uncle he just couldn't figure out again
through winter yeah there's some spec
there's some that's accurate because I
sometimes can't forget doing that so
it's tough man uncle was struggling open
the clothes it's rough windows a tree
there like almost a door but they don't
quite function as one
when one opens and closes I think that's
the ancient property 3 ok another bot
also could not just get it together with
the hey just humble leave no you guys
took it back oh oh it's so close the end
- Callaghan
just find our box for you no BOTS come
back don't do it boy I'll do it
you can hear that they're at a point no
teammate bad buzz oh I got one yeah Jake
out in the GameSpot office got the
Bronze Star this time okay we are going
to switch over to war those your team
the Gunners bronzer it's not last kill
anymore wow great game even settle that
skill now sure thing no no that's cool
cool you had one more player you told
her guys just there's boxes in a window
and you couldn't do them both it looks
like that's what happened to Uncle I
could shoot him I had time to reload and
then pull it back up and shoot him while
he was like do it but not just going to
do this my vampire all right tucked into
a corner to reload and as I'm reloading
what are your BOTS came around the
corner and he stopped and he back
pedaled a ninja
we did dance which I think he was
following whichever one he was running
out the bad hat he was like it's
insulting because they could if they
were a player killing me so much quicker
so I just have to watch that kill cam
where they like I'm just an idiot
sitting there and you can skip the kill
cam just do it when it's really
embarrassing oh so that's it okay I'm
ready okay so we are gonna jump into war
mode next so get ready for that war mode
is new and so it's it's a little bit
different there are some objectives and
so some of you will be defending like
one of you will be defending and the
other team will be attacking and then
you'll switch off so that'll be a lot of
fun but let's jump into that very soon
cool let's see if there's anyone in the
chat if you're just tuning in we're
playing Call of Duty World War two its
launch day this is all brought to you by
Activision and we are playing with screw
attack and the warp zone they're here
going up against each other except for
one random match where they split up we
are playing for one more hour so you
will be here till 1:00 p.m. Pacific time
and we're gonna jump into war mode so
this is war do something in the next
quarter tank okay
are we attacking they're defending we
are oh there's a cutscene and everything
is with our characters there's Harry
he's our boss he's good these guys he's
a hardened team oh this is cool Charlie
maybe this time I'll do something okay
here we go pretend it's my dick what
does that say to where it's a defend I
got a weight had post that sorry if you
guys are defending are we attachment I
would assume so I guess
caPSURE command post yep that gave the
way sometimes look there was a lot of
storing that's a low defensive yeah whoa
surprise I was here okay they were the
thing that was uh worrying me as I
didn't know how big or how little this
map would be since there's a campaign
type thing
well yeah it's it's very which is cool
we did one right anything's pretty
quickly
yeah I mean real dick move there kid
yeah oh there's three spawn time
interests oh there is yeah that's
different on your kill cam you will see
that I definitely didn't realize you
were an enemy at first and just look at
you beedo all your backup is dead yep do
we shouldn't get uh yeah we just got a
capture just got a stand in that
building try it feels like that's
something you don't actually want him to
do yep
Oh an aide on this class crap oh shoot I
was not thinking with it on all this I
know they don't all just come like it's
blackface just definitely happen yeah
hold on they're capturing it get back in
who Davis yep I heard that I mean go
back to melee only yes surprise Oh fair
for them they're doing it but the box
are like building walls up and stuff the
cream yeah yeah maybe that's like
showing I don't know I'm gonna find out
here in a second but there's like
zombies where you go to the thing and
interact with it to like build up a wall
and you know maybe you need to be
certain class oh my goodness oh I want
out of the death house
well this breach the door well we see
panic we have one good push yeah don't
let me tell you get your one good push
or two two decent push come on Sam
that's not how this game I'm trying to
hold back these pushes your bots aren't
gonna do it so think about if you let us
capture it you can see the next phase on
this level is a man who knows how to
argue
she bought Davis you don't like him say
you sure yeah oh God
that was my grenade I just heard okay I
was like killed we're saying is hanging
here
throwback what did you play throwback oh
no for some reason I've planted
explosives when you read throwback you
just thought I was talking about a
previous time okay I blew up our wall
not sure why there we go oh yeah you can
get some tuned see our bots are building
back up I guess yeah if nothing else our
BOTS and oh how the bills yes
get I love this guy it looks like you
don't have killstreaks nope you don't
[Music]
switch now now you try and sit my house
yeah we got it was that your plane oh
that might have been yet so you guys
might know how expensive that plane is
that's really gonna hurt our fourth
quarter yeah round is over teams will
switch allowing the defending team to
attack and vice versa
all right all right good trick out your
trial you can't modify no you can't
modify the class with its variables this
is great I got a girl robbery
yeah we have a diverse group of
evildoers yeah every time we do well I
just reminded we're on the bad side of
the world
somebody's got to do it I guess yeah
we're allies now it's flops no no no yes
who's doing it no you know it swaps
we're okay build or something whatever
you guys are building there's one in the
barn
oh I got two you lived up to your name
what are you doing Harry our but Harry
is just running away from the house he's
running back to our base he's scared
fears real she's gotta slap him have a
good talk with him you know yeah that
the motivation here smack him once in
there hysterical then he just like a
good time we got to do this or is very
sensible for Harry
oh yeah think that shoot
double kill I'm just sitting here being
sneaky don't tell them I'm here
oh yeah now we gonna do a bridge or
something like that
oh he captured it yeah that's how you
sit in the house guys come on in the
house boy I guess cuz that was you have
a lot of people in there that kept quick
I was just sitting in a corner like not
shooting or doing anything
I was I was sneaking around killing
people as they tried to get back to
their seem to do well alright
this is we gotta build this bridge
there's a guy up top build that bridge
enemy flamethrower sir get to cover I
thought this character didn't have fall
damage yeah it let me I feel like I'm
building a torque turret right now how
do you build this day how do you do Oh
forgot it
are you a bill or you're alive all right
this is gonna be really dangerous I know
we are building [ __ ] out of this bridge
right now what is this oh there's a zone
of no return you can't go all right no
that's actually really smart
because what I was going to do was I was
gonna run into their base and I was
gonna spawn camping because it was gonna
four spawn and they go and they thought
of that they will they literally do they
ain't even kill you if you stay too far
behind enemy lines yeah
there you go that really glad they
switched our side for the axis of
Arivaca like an ultimate victory yeah
nothing oh I don't know the building
here I guess they just built the thing
Oh what
guess who can be in the tank turret
they're flankin dang what sure it was
there I think you have to clean up our
guys over here you guys planet okay oh
forgot I'm a Nazi can't can't shoot
other Nazis this boy I wish that was on
my screen okay yeah that didn't work on
that one I was too far away
what's going on over here
where's this thing uh oh oh okay yeah
well that's it a bomb we gotta defend
the ball to defuse it somebody in that
or dude yeah I'm up in the tank killing
yo anyway I didn't realize how close he
was gonna close so I was like trying to
jump the wall right when it blew up it
didn't go so good for me what you al
azhar the realizes you're helping us
commit insurance fraud we actually these
buildings can check out some good policy
in this stuff yeah wait what
Oh Toby stop how do we stop hey it's
like a halo you just gotta keep people
off it you cannot stop the tank then
probably this how y'all get these plans
bro oh my gosh so many also yeah where's
it how do you get Flint er I don't know
I've seen a couple box with them I mean
like the bots know much more than we do
yeah I'm not good at applying their
knowledge Oh who's up in there okay oh
my body got smushed by the tank and in
the religions are like a paste oh you're
so close that's why my hair's not pasted
yet I changed it push your back guys
move that tank the audience
participation yeah the game show now
yeah you remember the audience
participation homework there's so many
of you good guys will sit here wait what
oh oh that was he sick nasty grenade oh
thank you I threw it oh he's just laying
there I'm hoping a prayer and it work
out how we're so close to it come on it
uh so I had the prompt to throw it back
but I backed away also so I end up just
pulling out my own grenade and then you
blew me up
yes triple grenade kill and now we're
gonna get the scarcely done
I'm in here too we had a rough first
start yeah how did that feel
what do you think warm oh yes oh it's
fun yeah I really liked all the
different objectives he's like the house
one felt pretty standard but then it was
like build the bridge you guys are all
there I'm gonna get this and just see
bullets just hit you dude kills but I'm
like but they are shoot they're slowly
left so the are bridge what I ended up
doing was I crawled in prone through the
pile of corpses building warps on what
do you think of war mode it's cool yeah
I'm ready to try I'm getting the feel
for it now yeah ready for another one
gonna win this one I need to get like a
I have a up close flow down and I have a
long range loadout
I need to figure out like mid range
loadout put your sweet spot loadout
telling you the N 1 grand or the bayonet
you're good all the time
so you stab people alright I feel like
we've gotten to know each other well no
check out the bar it's an assault rifle
huh it's really really really good works
all at longer in gentlemen and closer
okay we're not a good session back into
war we're somewhere in Germany okay
escort EMI sorting caption capturing
something no smoking escorting an IV
German how do you what does that scope
mean I think it's objectives to reach
secured the bridge I don't understand
what I don't know that's just a
different language I'm gonna give this
bar a try
he just spoke very highly of bar
sometimes the bars what you need all
right like it has the dorkiest glasses
rolling okay your x-ray yeah come on
guys
okay what are we doing halting we can do
it forward there's three tangos yes
ma'am oh that's that is a little
disconcerting Sam oh why do all of our
friends oh they're right there
they're right there oh this is
interesting
I was not expecting that
oh I didn't pick the right gun for this
one okay all right
season on the move dear friends each
pull with it not weird out nope nope
duper do we have to get every tank there
yes ok wait want to just bring one tank
yeah are you I know you're here hi there
oh no he shot me run out of it I didn't
get to kill anybody with it I like this
bar yeah I did it's really good
[ __ ] from YouTube from Plex p.m. how
do you feel the hitboxes are very
accurate or some delay very accurate
nice okay there you go sorry you were
asking so many times I just saw your
question every time I've missed a killer
felt like it's my fault yeah this is
what I'm not people Mike again oh you
just have to get so you just had to get
one do setting in one line I didn't know
I thought it would get all of them
chances games no not today
let's know everything yeah oh oh yeah
like now it's the just tells us to grab
something
Oh what are we grabbing I'm gonna think
it's a bomb maybe destroy that image
maybe it's a flag you were the big hand
we gotta come on we got to demoralize
them remember
my ax i we end a little peak Oh what is
our wheeze there's two things now gotta
get two tanks I don't know hundred
percent I think there's just defend
things that say defend I don't know I
just keep trying to grab the thing and I
don't know oh this guy yeah it does a
valid stand I gotta give you know we're
trying to steal tank fuel I believe oh
okay yeah we got to pick it up and run
it that's what we got it someone's in
and fuel up the tank before we shut up
here I blame a crazy German should've
thought of that so they're too busy
making sure that the bad guys gonna
probably be right in there we're gonna
do this see how that plays out oh whoa
oh you don't see I'm dodging bullets are
you back on the bar dude I'm trying yeah
yeah I'm back on the bar but where's it
been probably oh that did they get no
it's reset it's like capture the flag
yeah you got it you gotta grab it and
touch it to reset it I think I hit a guy
with a grenade and it killed him like
physically threw it into his body
yeah that can happen to a hole it's
great
what no my corpse is touching it but
turn it sucks oh you did the
flamethrower really that's trying to get
the tank fuel can't see him through the
fire of your corpse die faster why would
you use a flamethrower right next to
tank fuel hella dangerous No oh all
right this one's harder can't we can do
oh there's a bar oh damn it it's not a
preset aah where's your wall now oh
you're in the quarter how dare you
confidently defend your gas tank me it
needs fuel think way harder than
anything else yeah well you know which
one we should set hope gas is don't let
up people fight over waste of time oh no
no I really want this gas well that's
gonna do you have any tank fuel on your
cart just water okay I'm gonna give this
thing thank you you know what oh no hold
on trying to be strong warfare distract
them so we can hit the fuel
oh thanks Richard here on the other side
of this tank are you on you got on the
tank
okay oh there's a lot of you that scared
me half to death and been over to that
one yet so we need to coordinate our
exact same yeah you want to come over
here and help me mm-hmm
no we need somebody over itby are you
all right we got it now we got to defend
him
I'm the finish I'm defending the [ __ ]
out of him who's got it
yeah Oh doing it he did it
hi goddamnit alright well there's
overtime surprise Oh reloading
what are you doing this it takes too
long you ran feels like oh no and then I
didn't die right away so like oh must be
teammate they just got a Supply Drop
oh right around the corner to the left
I've done a lot this time well luckily
it's a objective think not a death thing
where's this fire coming from I think
that people are picking up stuff oh look
up there it's pretty hard we're gonna
make it though we're gonna make it
no yeah headshot Oh
Oh Oh Chad on the one Jews
I'm getting some work done right now
Chad your push was one for the history
books
thanks dad I'm still going by the way oh
I mean I'm not machines oh no no Hornets
being sneaky there in the corner oh I
had to get rough
all right out of him oh my gosh face was
so bloody they just did the tank up
there okay
can do it oh no you just gotta push back
push me push Oh
philanthropy oh there's a lot of
explosions in there that's oh thank you
pushing up trying whoo I really like
this is a lot of fun yeah this war mode
is awesome
Oh shot me with wagon my guy was like
holding it hey guys catch grenade what's
crazy too is when you hung up our
indication you can't see what's your
team anymore so I am just like my not
terrified for shooting you yep
that's all I have a gun with a lot I am
I'm just I just fire you don't even
worry about LMG fuel the gas yeah man
that guy crazy this motus how are those
tanks by yes are you do you have more
health when you're in them no I don't
think so
so if you're just tuning in we're
playing the new mode war and Call of
Duty World War II brought to you by
Activision that's what you're checking
out right now we're at halftime so they
can switch sides so now the opposite
team is going to defend the opposite
team is going to attack
we're the good guys finally
you're watching team ScrewAttack right
now I feel bad morning with team warp
zone good probably should've check the
left side too okay they pushed in see
harder right now well I was doing a
screwed it up real very singly Oh
besides you gotta really feels very
happy about oh yeah with the gun bullets
it's really hard to stop all three tanks
from getting here it's blocked these
block Davis how do you get past you
gotta blow up the thing I know but I
also have to fight won't fight fight
while I plant this well that doesn't
work
oh really that just didn't kill him huh
today there is I'll get it if you say
I'm gonna I gotta I'm healed no oh no I
just read it into the taste line of fire
Oh your your pay yeah you're kiddin find
these things suck okay yeah it's pretty
rough
I just I'm in the gym I'm doing what I
can but if someone needs a sweet okay
how do you do that they're gonna get
Scott coming no he was ready for me
do you like he's doing a better job
killing in the tank than I ever was the
cool thing about the tank is she goes so
slow that I'm like I'm always ready I'm
just like I push that with my life oh he
didn't see oh no trying man good see you
can see it see
so we did push all three right no no
they just need to get one here but this
just determines how many well why did I
pick up that grenade no now they're
doing a sneaky a mistake you know no big
it did on a man yeah I'll try to get it
they must halt it
oh no get back to the field up why is it
saying I'm gonna die cuz you're behind
him anyway enemy lines
yeah I hear that's what you guys alright
forward momentum remember oh they're
gonna get that a like immediately you
just grab the fuel like right away
you know one went to a except I did but
I got outplayed some fear so we won
they're done with the fuel what we get
three no we gotta think I get three okay
order that takes a lot yeah oh that's
for you
yeah how you like the burger nut no that
will help I um I'll be focusing on
dependent a mm-hm you do whatever you do
I'm doing it I got this idiot bought
with me no oh no oh man I got concussed
the right of the opportune moment for
that did not go well
you can check your chats doing ok let's
see how you guys doing over in chat send
your questions and comments what do you
guys think of war mode I'm watching it
here let us know do I have the shovel
it's not on my back here's the show I
still don't know what the shovel guys I
think it's a Sheltie mm-hmm Edgar gee
there's no killstreaks in war mode no
there's not a war mode and I think they
probably tried it it probably was not
bad he has a third one coming shed how
many bots do you have with Oh overlord I
don't know and his wave thrower is
theirs Oh grizzly only one not doctors
what in the world no Maori yes did you
see that
they're strong whoo what's your home
tank fuel looks like steroids again yeah
I'm living juiced up escorting their
tank across long it up for us laughs
great and halt their advance
man they're on top flanked Oh sometimes
you spawn so far yeah like long run back
there sneaking on you go for the long
throw this might be the place to use the
bazooka yeah yeah it might be oh who is
it
the cords oh my uh hijack that's your
idea sounds smart
oh great yeah I was like I don't know
what's happening corpse corpse kills
into the tank Quadra kill like it's on
ha yep
there's only one guy left on their team
right then I'll avenge my bot how did
that I kill him I'm dead no my good guy
yep always been someone we thought
you're still in there no I did you
change it dance oh this is getting rough
what's our pod doing one man okay
yeah
[Music]
yeah we gotta get out there good I tried
I tried to make an epic stand thank you
just in the turret area they saw I was
shooting tons of people I'm coming oh oh
why is this darn you so far back I may
not be hungry to hop into is just not
there that's totally not target and
that's right until it
yeah sneaky spy Oh mm oh no no remember
him please want to kill me oh we've all
definitely [ __ ] stuff yeah be fun
banter
significantly died cause it's serious
time you know what no I got it
no no no no no no no fight to the last
man find them
little ghost oh yeah oh it's rolling
backwards a little bit yeah I had one
where it was I can easily defend the
finger whatever it was like I had a
grenade they got three cousins like
right at spawn and let us take the next
thing good game wow that war is this
version of Horace fun
[Laughter]
but you can your is great yeah all right
I think we have enough time for one more
warm-up but we're gonna take just a
little breather right now we are playing
Call of Duty World War two on launch day
brought to you by Activision we've got
screw attack and the warp zone in the
house and they're checking out war mode
it's a new mode in multiplayer in this
game how are you guys feeling I know
that was very heavy sometimes we get
very silent just a lot of focus like
what do you what are you guys thinking
yeah it reminds me of like no fluff back
in college we would set up two TVs and
play is that a modern warfare 2 that we
and it was like just people like right
next to each other being like oh so this
gets superseded reminds me that yeah
getting that like having to do the
objectives over and over again and them
changing keeps it fresh and it's very
very sure this is the action to it [ __ ]
just like running around team deathmatch
so yeah those we're like go tank it's
not like that one with Gibraltar where
you're like where are people yeah got it
per your recommendation oh well that's
good just make the best of what you've
got ok it's gonna be fine
you do great so this is the very last
war mo that we are playing in this
stream so good luck involved
yeah oh I forgot to change to access so
I might get auto-generated we'll see I
guess I'll see we drop in yeah I was
focused on goodness let's see where am I
yeah so I can't swim okay I've messed up
I'm on your team now press the option of
the girl our plunge change team there
this is this is d-day
I got you saying I'm here I did some
enemy recon there at the beach I just
know that wow this is tough we got
building this thing oh hey this is
Normandy right yes that's turn two are
you saying
let me tell you yeah your x-ray actually
I just had a very awesome dude this
sniper life is amazing this is intense
ah I figure one of them is capturing and
just ran away no way hello
to be fair you seen a lot of people die
oh it's a bad bot oh oh no I did too
whoever fillet jump me he's too good
curses upon your family you can hear me
Oh bees almost there
yep my lives in the other corner of
course let's play
yep that was just a bomb yeah
quite literally an uphill battle
what aha you know one thing I really
like is they don't show your kill count
in this so people can't try and turn it
into a deathmatch yeah I mean yeah but
they don't know how many kills it
doesn't incentivize you to do they're
not actually gonna count with your hands
or something that doesn't happen out
there
Oh your guy
Wow first yep
this is just people everywhere now I
will tell you sniping in that original
part was so much fun
I'm telling you if you need the
character oh I don't we wanted
perspective Nate then it's crazy [ __ ]
the turret yeah yeah but you don't get
shot say how many do if they make it
around that's a case that me
the bots will stop them don't worry
yeah are they here Oh of course right is
like right as I say that I circling the
turret and they were there five people
in a row like x-rays coming he's getting
stabbed oh my god
well I went out for a stabbing and they
did VIP and Sabbath's rates over there
were people with guns yo if you have a
pistol you can pistol with people to
enjoy it's awesome if you have the
bazooka you can bazooka with people is
it whatever just a little [ __ ]
yeah whatever good you're working with
you're you're whipping I'm Lincoln I got
a surprise
I spend like an hour getting to that one
yeah yeah I been like alright start over
again
whoa double headshots Chet yeah try I
tried to keep it going
figure that wouldn't expect the rush
after the grenade the screams in this
manner ten oh you got a double kill
Larry Davis Oh goddamn it
and they're both like nice like I just
was shooting your feet
turns out there yes sir hmm no I would
like a better spot let me destroy his
friends yeah oh there we are destroy
area the columns equipment something up
there ten of them I know what this is oh
I know what this is now oh oh man I am
NOT doing good I had it and the stuff at
the beginning of the beach I was just
killing it now I'm not doing good at all
I'm dropping the ball plant Oh God oh
yeah there's a hole there
hello we need to find
okay let's flip uh did you plan it yep I
can't just rebuild it they can but it'll
take a second oh I got it mmm she's
trying fine
a guy came up inside of our vase well
technique Whitman oh no oh that's not
good I stopped I think you guys wanted
me to make me climb the ladder how do I
just
gosh darn it whose nothing gonna kills
it like how do I destroy it produce unit
square probably square or shoot it yeah
it's almost it's like on the ceiling
you're not cool
Oh know what that person came from but I
stabbed the [ __ ] out of them yeah you
got really just like fell down the
ladder and I was like Oh stab you do
here yeah I'm a bit at a loss to I'm
just like okay there's objective
oh we just heard something I think if my
I think you might just yeah you know
just grenade it did we destroy two
things is it just just general damage
today I think it might be just general
damage
oh good we're yet you can tell that
blink and more discovery all right three
things destroyed oh it's philanthropy
there's bullying right there so we can't
Ben is on stop the exercise just run in
try to do as much damage yeah and then
just get killed
gosh darn it George well there with the
language gee willikers George oh come on
my look at it idiot runs with a grenade
out and then after he died looting you
haven't liked George
heard you coming Hey
oh well I thought I could disarm it No
yeah are you trying to disarm a grenade
they put on oh yeah I put a blast on the
door so they could rush in faster oh
he's just running through bayonetta
people hey it's effective that's what it
takes
Oh
Oh No yeah
oh there's a bunch of them in there now
this bad this real quick okay
I kept flying at the elbow yeah but most
exciting
almost hey listen some sort of no I
don't think so seven out of ten oh the
respawns I realize you can tow the wall
even if it's disadvantageous for you
yeah yeah yeah I don't know why I let
you do that but hey sometimes you just
gotta build man sometimes you want to
create it's not in your best little
Minecraft in there just for fun yeah so
we were in half em in our very last war
match so who's defending now we're
defending all right I had so much fun
being a sniper and that initial defense
on memory because it's all of you were
running up the beach you're just like
taking them off it was pretty cool this
is gonna be rough good luck it was
Saving Private Ryan
conkers bad fur big Saving Private Ryan
oh yeah just go yeah my favorite games
all the time
oh come on
Oh Oh
I can't even all right that this is
really cool
do they are they're like random NPCs
Judith yeah dying yep there are the
strain of NBC's oh I think we did the
hard part
no there's still one up in that window
yes it's really hard to get to that base
a is the easy one I don't believe you
yeah we already got the wall blown up
for being too that's done by that
explosion guy those turrets there's
millions of peaches sitting up there
oh I declare [ __ ] no job three
wheels get a day so no one if you guys
had backed me up we would have had it
but one of our BOTS is firing at you up
in a from the river blaring from the
ocean he's just chilling sis what do ya
got off with six yeah okay yeah okay
come eight yeah what sugars but I spawn
over on the side yeah we've almost got
Oh still contested oh he's waiting on
the ladder yeah sneaky sneaky then we
just there's so many grenades into a hey
Jesus there we go nice Mini's just spawn
really far out here in the water some
days yeah we got a other oh now we have
to get B you have to get both yeah we do
but yeah both yep we have to get both it
was the boss culture day
no I did no no oh when you're attacked
like the [ __ ] box captured their
interns B that's where it gets really
really intense
oh the Becker name oh all right walking
over a corpse on fire sets you on fire
means fire oh no families have it there
oh there's two of you all right there we
go having five of you he's got a ladle
in her bag looks like her chefs in the
game
no yeah we were both reloading I was
like who's gonna get it first who's
gonna get it oh no oh why did I explode
you'll [ __ ]
and we'll come tear it down oh god what
was that that rocket launcher on the
ground you sure know the bazooka isn't
as you you want it to be awesome kind of
wish I have to how you shotgun set up
uh-huh
good bye this might be like a time to do
it come on George
oh there's a grave down that wall Oh
damn it Sam trying over here I didn't
know that you guys had a Bond girl so I
randomly all right I'm gonna I'm gonna
defend this place this be my place and
many pools of them hey won't you let you
know that I was blowing up some barbed
wire and one of your teammates ran right
past me and it was super
but was it a bot where do we go yeah
they're ready they're all in there right
now
yeah we're killing a lot of [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah watch out specially in
close quarters and then you just do this
and yeah that flamethrower pretty much
just cleans at the room we almost got it
ah let's see I'm gonna sacrifice yeah
it's kind of hard to okay here we go
find the ones that's there's one letting
up they glow just just three minutes
boys we got this all we need is one more
thing blowing up where is it right now
guys laying down on the floor over there
watch out like once you walk into the
left walking on the right side which way
they come not just like everywhere
breeds something on your left on your
okay I know where it is okay it's over
on the far side the right side when we
return it no it's on the what's episode
that he did jump he was just like all
right I played it on war there's one
more killed so many of them where is it
then here still yes they're done no job
Sam active complete no not our big guns
we just got these put in Oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
no no I am very like yeah there's this
uh oh there's just a place we can't
cross we got a triple kill because we
were sitting there trying to plant a
bomb yeah no fruit dude about it I could
hand me I don't know where I am
Oh Lauren did not help
oh okay bean there's a guy I go aviation
air
my organs I don't know probably blow it
up
well Anthony's at a we have three BOTS
hanging out of the someone did something
to be oh oh they have flamethrowers how
do the bots can get in one of our BOTS
made this stupid wall or whatever and
see whatever it's like this alright good
so hard you want to like use a longer
range gun when you're trying to make it
in but once you're in you'll really want
yep at close quarters are they just is
it a thing you tip the squad on awesome
I got no you have to hold you don't know
we got hey what happened I thought we
had a yeah just gone down our Dean's
gone now I really here's I want to use
the flamethrower Oh God yeah yeah yeah
Oh Bernie take that alright don't see
where we go on the next one alright
final thoughts on war mode guys screw
tech really fun I think they both have
their place like I think it's gonna be a
really good mode to like mix it up when
you're like if you start to feel like oh
you know I've done deathmatch and all
these kill modes like over and over
again give you something a little bit
different it like man it really does
like get you into engaging it was what
do you think warp zone it made me care
about radios yeah it's fun always like a
classic you know it's a good distraction
between yeah like yeah changes it up
keeps it fresh modes yeah awesome
alright well any final thoughts on the
game guys
that didn't feel like two hours I can
keep just it's like four yeah yeah yeah
but no just advice for anybody who's
wondering if they thinking about picking
it up if you were a fan of like the less
like jetpack II run all over the walls
Call of Duty this is like a breath of
fresh air what it used to be I'm super
excited
awesome yeah any less words you guys oh
yeah I feel like you're watching not
jetpacks rocket going flamethrower yeah
yeah
nice alright well thank you guys so much
for watching our Call of Duty World War
2 livestream on launch day the game is
out now so if you want to play if you
were intrigued by what you just saw go
ahead and check out the game it's out on
ps4 Xbox one and PC and four more things
about Call of Duty World War two go to
gamespot.com thanks
[Music]